Did you miss me?
(Screams)
Oh Lord,
help me get
through this game.
Everyone's a liar.
I can't be trusted.
I'm trying to win.
She’s a stone
cold killer.
It's just gossip.
I think she
could be banished.
This is some
bullsh*t.
Ooh this is
getting intense.
Welcome to an
all-new season
of strategy,
betrayal,
sabotage,
and murder.
With higher
stakes...
Alan's dropping
another bombshell.
This guy is the
silent slaughterer.
(Shrieks)
diabolical twists...
She's the traitor.
Why would I want
to murder
her boyfriend?
Come on.
Hurry! Go, go, go!
...and a killer
all-celebrity cast.
People
keep throwing
the Housewives
out there
as traitors.
I don't think
they've got it
in them.
This is not
The Bachelor,
and I don't have to
kiss your a**
for a rose.
Who will win
a quarter of
a million dollars?
I was born ready.
And who will
win a plot
in my graveyard?
I'm coming
after that gold.
You want to work
together
and get
somebody out?
If she talks
sh*t about me
I'm gonna have to.
The first signs
of deception...
I’m going to
take care of her
once and for all.
There's no
friendships
in this game.
I find you highly
annoying.
It's just a ton
of chaos.
Hold on to
your kilts, dearies.
The games
are just beginning.
Too much?
So, how does it
feel to be
the second best
dressed guy?
I'd say...
back off, b*tch.